[Musik]
heute ist kein normaler tag denn heute
treffe ich mein idol
markus söder denn der tod gerade durch
bayerische kinos mit seinem
erfolgsprogramm söder persönlich wir
haben sie ein plakat hier hängen gehabt
und da haben wir die leute gefragt wann
läuft ist eigentlich der film im süden
kommt dahin waren kam die eigentliche
und die chance habe ich ihm erzählt dass
er praktisch als filmheld angesehen
worden
deshalb sei ja auch wenn man noch
ehrliches oder schaut gut aus kann man
nicht sagen
[Musik]
das ist einfach eine top typ einfach
muss man ja ist und ob sie ihren mann
für markus söder verlassen
theoretisch wenn ihm nicht kennen würde
ein mann der tat in bayern eine große
persönlichkeit
nach horst seehofer nach horst seehofer
das wird doch nicht gerne hören
deswegen hat seehofer jetzt in berlin
und macht das bestimmt seinen job nicht
schlecht clever gemacht er markus oder
nicht zu unterschätzen ja einen kleinen
wettbewerb wer markus söder von uns
geiler findet also ich finde ich geil
und sie ja doch sie sich steigern
supergeil
[Gelächter]
erotisch aufgeladen viel spaß dass
günter gleich sind so aufgeregt bist
oder
[Applaus]
[Musik]
unterschreiben sie ein bisschen was ich
bin ihr größter fan sagen ja aber nicht
das mikro wegnehmen was machen sie
weiter aus ich bin ihr größter fan
das heißt ich will so werden sie wie sie
mit anderen worten ich will meinen chef
brutal wegbomben dazu müssen sie nur
sehr erwachsen junger mann und eines
tages wird das ihnen auch noch ein
intendant
jetzt haben sie mich so gerückt wie
seehofer aber immerhin habe ich die eier
mein chef jetzt schon weg zu morgen und
nicht zu warten bis er alte und
gebrechliche sondern
[Applaus]
[Musik]
ich bin extra ganz leise das ist einfach
toll
das ist wirklich ein ganz großer ich
habe noch nie so viele gehaltvolle worte
gehört das ist erst einmal eine frau zu
hause war
da kam die begegnung mit meinem hund
also nicht so weil ich stand am garten
ton klingt dann haben wir später drüber
gehabt jetzt haben ein motto und so
einem zweig bücher und bilder an fanny
und also hunde sind einfach super
es war wirklich haben wir das gar nicht
so toll vorgestellt wird das wirklich
warten war richtig ist und gerade im
kino den dichter atmosphäre also mehr
kann man nicht verlangen
man geht ja eigentlich ins kino um zu
knutschen ja aber bisschen schade wenn
der schwarm hat vorne auf der bühne sind
genauso da ich bin deutsche größter fan
sie mir noch was unterschreiben sie mal
hier was ich haben es angezogen
können sie das nicht unterschreiben nein
ich habe extra nein danke nur ein
autogramm dass ich mir zu hause
aufhängen kann ich habe sogar noch so
ein schild mit einem sind andere
gucken sie mal ist das nicht schön kann
man es ja nicht so wenn es die ganze
redaktion trägt dann schon
natürlich ist glaube jetzt ist er hier
eine unterschrift tut ihnen deutlich weh
oder nein da war ich extra beim söder im
kino und habe nicht nur ein autogramm
gekriegt geh ich halt nach hause kommt
mir den richtigen action film bibi und
tina zum betrieb
haben wir ein fester